veamos si podemos aplicar algunas de
nuestras nuevas herramientas para
resolver integrales así que vamos a
decir que tenemos la integral de línea a
lo largo de una curva cerrada que ya
veremos cuál es de x cuadrada massieu
cuadrada y esto lo multiplicamos por de
x + + 2x y por de ella
muy bien ahora nuestra curva se va a
estar definida por vamos a ver la
parametrización de esta curva será x
igual a coseno de t y vamos a poner allí
igual a seno de t
y esto será válido para ti entre 0 t
entre 0 y 2 p y bueno esto es
básicamente un círculo verdad un círculo
de radio 1 en el plano xy ahora vamos a
ver si podemos utilizar nuestros
descubrimientos de los vídeos anteriores
para simplificar este proceso lo primero
que vamos a ver es bueno esto parece si
una integral de línea pero allí de equis
de y yo no veo la f ni el de r no está
claro que sea realmente una integral de
línea verdad así que lo que queremos
hacer en este primer ejercicio y que
realmente es el objetivo del ejemplo es
reescribir esto como una integral de
línea para mostrar que uno puede tener
otras formas de escribirlo verdad así
que empecemos con nuestra curva r de t
pues no voy a ponerlas las funciones
simplemente pondré x dt x y más 7 x jota
que es nuestra parametrización de la
curva y hemos visto que de r
de t es decir la derivada de r respecto
de éste simplemente derivar cada una de
las entradas de x de t por más de 7 por
jota ahora también hemos visto que si
uno quiere obtener el diferencial de r
entonces multiplicamos todo por desde
verdad entonces uno se deshace de la dt
del lado izquierdo y multiplica por de
este del lado derecho por lo tanto las
dt se van a cancelar verdad verdad
realmente tratamos de t como como si
fuera un número así que nos queda de x
por i + d y por j
y esto ya es la diferencia ya podremos
ver algún patrón por ahí verdad ahora si
definimos nuestro campo vectorial fx y
como x cuadrada más cuadrada y esto lo
multiplicamos por el vector y y ahora
sumamos 2x y por jota por el vector j
pues qué es esto que es lo que tenemos
aquí bien pues efe punto de r que es lo
que tenemos en la fórmula de las
integrales de línea pues será x cuadrada
más cuadrada que multiplica de x verdad
eso multiplica de x
ahora vamos a obtener esta componente x
cuadrada más cuadrada que multiplica
como ya lo dije a de x
y ahora sumamos el resultado de
multiplicar las segundas componentes
verdad que en este caso es 2x por d
y ese es el resultado del producto punto
ahora esta cosa de la derecha que estoy
subrayando es idéntica al integrando de
nuestra integral de línea verdad así que
ya lo podemos poner como como en un
formulario ya estamos ahora pues
familiarizados con esta anotación verdad
donde si se es esta curva esto es la
integral de línea de este campo
vectorial
efe déjenme escribirlo en otro color de
nuestro campo efe punto de r perfecto
así que esto es una integral de línea
simplemente que reescrito de otra forma
muy bien si ya en un futuro ves esta
forma pues puedes decir ok pues es una
forma de escribir una describir un
integral de línea perfecto donde pues
cada una de estas serán nuestras
componentes verdad
ahora bien
e inmediatamente lo que lo que se sabe
del campo vectorial es que estamos
tomando una integral de línea donde cada
una de estas funciones representa las
componentes nos podemos preguntar bueno
efe es conservativo porque si efe es el
gradiente de algún campo escalar f
mayúscula como ya vimos en él en el
vídeo anterior pues podemos resolver
esta integral de línea fácilmente verdad
si encontramos esta función f cuyo
gradiente sea el campo vectorial
entonces f es conservativo y como
estamos haciendo un integral de línea
sobre una curva cerrada pues entonces
esta integral de línea sería cero verdad
sería simplemente cero se anula así que
una vez que si es que podemos demostrar
que es un campo conservativo es más ni
siquiera necesitamos saber quién es la
curva verdad
así que vamos a tratar de ver si
encontramos esta f mayúscula que cumpla
esta condición que su gradiente sea esta
función efe
muy bien eso significaría que que la
derivada parcial de nuestra función f
mayúscula respecto de x tiene que ser la
primera coordenada del campo vectorial
que en este caso es x cuadrada más
cuadrada
y también nos dice que la derivada
parcial de esta f mayúscula respecto de
y tiene que ser igual a la segunda
componente del campo vectorial que en
este campo caso es 2x y ahora nada más
como repaso el gradiente de f recordemos
que es la derivada parcial de f respecto
de x por el vector y más la derivada
parcial de f respecto de y por el vector
jota perfecto así que si queremos hacer
que sean iguales pues tenemos que hacer
iguales entrada por entrada como la
parcial de f respecto de x con x
cuadrada más cuadrada y la parcial de f
respecto de y con 2x que es justo lo que
escribimos acá abajo vamos a ver si
podemos encontrar una f que satisface
ambas ecuaciones así que primero
podremos tomar la integral respecto de x
de esta ecuación de la izquierda así que
si integramos respecto de x en ambos
lados consideramos a la i como una
constante verdad así que tendríamos f
cuál es la primitiva de x cuadrada pues
es x al cubo entre 3
y ahora la primitiva de cuadrada
respecto de x por supuesto en realidad
de cuadrada puede ser cualquier número
cada cinco lo que ustedes quieran así
que esto nos queda común x de cuadrada
verdad ahora a continuación podría haber
alguna función que dependa sólo de y
digamos una g de y porque de haber una
función que sólo dependa exclusivamente
de y al tomar la derivada parcial
respecto de x desaparece se hace cero
verdad por lo tanto si podríamos agregar
esta función sabemos que hay que agregar
una constante pero una constante pues es
una función de jeff para fines de
derivar respecto de x déjenme poner que
f depende explícitamente de estas dos
variables ahora pasemos al otro lado
para ver si podemos conciliar las dos
expresiones digamos si aquí integramos
respecto de y entonces nuestra efe es la
integral de 2x respecto
por lo tanto la equis pues es una
constante verdad sobre su número así que
la integral de dos en realidad es de
cuadrada por lo tanto esta integral nos
queda xy cuadrada y cómo integramos
respecto de de y pues tenemos que
agregar una constante pero una constante
para para fines de derivar respecto de y
puede ser cualquier función de x vamos a
ponerle efe minúscula de x
perfecto ahora vamos a tratar de
coincidir ambas ambas ecuaciones estas
dos estos dos datos entonces vamos a ver
qué tienen de parecido esencialmente lo
que podemos ver es que esta xy cuadrada
coincide en ambas expresiones muy bien
se ve bien y aquí tenemos una f que
depende exclusivamente de x no hay es y
aquí tenemos esta función que es x
cúbica entre 3 que sólo depende de x por
lo tanto podemos pensar que es la misma
aquí tenemos una g de iu pero del otro
lado no encontramos una función que
dependa de ella bueno no tan así así que
podríamos pensar que es una 0 10 verdad
en realidad una g de igual a 0 es una
función que depende explícitamente de i
y que puede ser 0 entonces a
continuación concluimos que nuestra f
mayúscula es x ubica entre 3 + xy
cuadrada ahora vamos a ver nada más
vamos a comprobar que el gradiente de
esta función es nuestro campo vectorial
original solo si no me creen lo que hice
anteriormente tomamos el gradiente de
efe y esto es la derivada parcial
respecto de x por cierto algunas
personas le ponen flechitas al operador
del gradiente pero bueno cuál es la
parcial de f respecto de x bueno la
derivada parcial de la primera parte es
simplemente x cuadrada verdad esto será
x cuadrada más que cuadrada es una
constante y al derivar x es 1 por lo
tanto nos queda x cuadrada massieu
cuadrada y multiplica al vector i y
ahora la derivada parcial respecto de la
primera parte sólo depende de x por lo
tanto se anula y ahora al derivar de
cuadrada tenemos 2 por x porque x era
constante y esto multiplica j
es exactamente nuestro campo vectorial
original que teníamos así que f en
realidad sí pudo escribirse como el
gradiente de un campo escalar f
mayúscula muy bien así que f
es conservativa este campo vectorial es
conservativa y eso nos dice que la
integral de líneas sobre esta curva
cerrada va a ser cero ya no importa cuál
fue la curva y ya terminamos podríamos
ignorar la parametrización de la curva
incluso